obvious that it is a tax rise
it's unfair because it hits working
people particularly those on lower
incomes and it isn't going to fix the
problem of social care
and i've been talking to people who are
going to be hit by effectively a double
whammy
because on the one hand they're getting
a tax rise of several hundred pounds at
the same time the government wants to
take away the thousand pounds in
universal credit uplift that we've seen
so some of these families 2.5 million
families are going to face the double
whammy of losing 11 1200 pounds a year
that's a huge amount of money it's
really unfair
and we should actually spread this
across those that can actually afford it
and would you keep that social care levy
would you keep the the universal credit
uplift in your next manifesto as well
well the government's acting as if
there's no alternative here they're
hammering working people
hammering working people
and we say it should be those with the
broader shoulders that should pay their
fair share so the government is saying
if you're working
we're going to tax you and i say well
people earn their income they're in
their money from other ways whether it's
property landlords
stocks shares dividends
those people should be paying their fair
way and the best example i can give you
is this a landlord with multiple
properties doesn't pay a penny more
his or her tenants who are in work pay
more tax
nobody could argue that that's a fair
way of doing this and on that point i
mean the prime minister said that
raising things like capital gains tax or
kind of raising tax on profits on assets
wouldn't be nearly enough money to fund
social care i mean what evidence do you
have that your alternative plans would
be enough to fund social care i don't
agree with the prime minister on that
our analysis is that you could raise
this money in other ways whether that's
capital gains tax whether that's
on property stocks and shares and
dividends he's not even trying
he's gone straight for
hammering working people and
last week i was speaking to rosie she's
a care worker
and this double whammy is going to mean
hundreds of pounds more for her and tax
87 pounds a month she's going to lose on
universal credit she's asked for more
shifts she can't get them she's got
child care issues it's people like rosie
care workers retail workers hospitality
workers who are getting hammered by this
government and on universal credit would
you keep that uplift permanently is that
something you put in your next manifesto
we've been fighting the government on
this uplift month in months out it is
wrong to remove that thousand pounds
uplift it will impact millions of
families who will be poorer because of
it
in the long run we would reform
and change universal credit because it
doesn't work well
particularly when people start to want
to earn a little bit more money they get
trapped in the system so we reform it in
the long run but
absolutely keep this uplift at the
moment it's a lifeline for millions of
families and would you what about the
social care levy that the government is
introducing is that something you would
keep to fund social care long term we
think there's an alternative which is to
fund this
in a broader way where those with the
broadest shoulders pay their fair share
and to put all of the burden on working
people
is wrong it's unfair and the thing about
this tax is it's a tax rise it's unfair
because it hammers working people and
it's not going to fix the problem we
don't even know when this money is
actually going to be paid
on social care at all
and it only addresses one small part of
the problem which is whether people have
to sell their homes
many people with moderate homes will
still have to sell their homes
the much bigger questions of
providing care
for people in their own homes paying the
workforce properly left completely
unaddressed by this and you've been
under some pressure to sort of provide
specific plans about your alternative i
mean how much would your alternative
plans raise do you think and also when
are we going to see your specific plans
for social care reform the principles
are very clear so let me set them out
firstly we must make sure that care is
provided at home the vast majority of
people want their care provided at home
so the question of going into a care
home is secondary the first question is
provide it at home
the second principle under our plan is
that this should be preventative there
are many bits of social care which
aren't provided at the moment if they
were it would actually prevent people
going into care homes in the long run
and the third issue that's really
important to our plan our principles is
that you've got to pay the workforce
properly care workers uh are underpaid
and undervalued and we want to see that
change and change materially by them
being paid more on more secure uh
contracts
and recognized for the hard work that
they put in so they're the principles of
the plan that we put forward and just
financially as well do you agree with
any kind of caps on care costs like the
ones that the government have introduced
what would you do differently well
nobody i think
likes to see people forced to sell their
homes in order to fund their care
the problem with the government's plan
is it's not going to address that
problem because if you've got a home
that's worth let's say about 160 000
pounds which would be an average across
the country
then you're still going to get hit for
the 86 000 pound uh to pay towards your
care and most people are not going to be
able to find 86 000 pounds without
selling their home people don't have
that kind of money and so yes addressed
the problem but not with this unfair way
the government's put forward and just
finally on this on this topic when might
we see a sort of fully costed plan that
labour would put forward as an
alternative option well the principles
are as i say out there and very clear
home first
is the first principle that we would
have in our plan
preventative is the second principle in
the plan so that we prevent the problems
um as they arise and prevent them
getting worse and then thirdly on the
workforce and how we improve the terms
and conditions of care workers in
particular quite a lot of that we set
out over the summer when we're dealing
with workplace rights
and just moving on to covid now as we
head into the winter i mean do you agree
with the government getting rid of some
of some of the covert restrictions like
the fact that they've signaled they're
very keen to get rid of pcr tests for
double vax travelers as soon as possible
do you think that should be going as we
head into winter i think everybody wants
to see restrictions
lifted
as best we can
but we've got to be cautious because for
everybody who says to me i want the
restrictions lifted they also say
understandably but i don't want to go
back into another lockdown nobody wants
that so what we've said is follow the
science
be careful be cautious and make sure
that whatever we do we don't go back
into another lockdown
do you agree on that point about pcr
tests i mean the government have said
that they are an unfair cost on families
who want to go away would you like to
see them scrapped as well i think some
of the costs been far too high for the
pcr test but i don't want to get rid of
the idea that tests should be available
to people who need them now travelling
is one aspect of this but what is
vitally important i think is that we
have free tests in our communities so
that people can get tested they know
when they have to isolate and we can get
the virus under control because the most
important thing is that now we have
opened up to a degree that we don't go
back into lockdown would you uh agree
with that do you agree with the
government's plans as well to not push
forward with covert vaccine passports in
england do you think that's the right
decision well the government's plans
change all of the time over the last six
months we've had any number of plans on
vaccine passports last few days we've
seen the government's position change
i think that vaccine passports
should never prevent people getting
essential services health dentistry the
sort of everyday essentials that people
need so shouldn't be a
shouldn't stop people getting those
essentials
possibly for some events they could be
used in conjunction with tests but never
on their own so it should always be an
alternative either a double vaccination
or a negative
test but as i say the most important
thing is that we shouldn't see vaccine
passports stopping people get what is
essential